in the lobby of the new terminal 2 of
heathrow airport in london
sweden at a height of up to 18 meters 77
tons of aluminum with a span
of 78 meters this is the longest
sculpture in
europe webstream by the
british sculptor richardson
imagine the whole thing  space of the
terminal would be filled with life and
then we take a plane and
shoot it in so it spins
tumbles flies dives and spins when
it flies out the other end
it would have dug a hole in the clay
that hole we are going to fill with fast
drying  imprint mass and remove
the remaining lives the remaining
imprint is the form of a movement from
a to
b i.e. the path of a passenger and that
’s what traveling is about at the
same time but it also captures the
moment of speed of flight
and power
his work on the building  by slipstream
, richard wilson compares that of a
conductor to his  The 61-
year-old couldn't implement the idea on his own to ensure
stability and security he had to guide
a team of
engineers and it specialists for years
slipstream was manufactured in 23 parts
and only assembled in terminal 2
we used the very latest
technology it was almost like building it  of an
airplane
you couldn't have built this sculpture five years ago
because the computer programs didn't
exist exciting or
when we started four years
ago our building material was clumsy and bulky
it was material that the
aviation industry had lent
us and they told us how to use it
must to create a sculpture that
embodies flight and speed
is one of the most important
contemporary uk sculptors
he has twice been
nominated for the turner prize
his works are large often
surprising and play with space as well as
a sculpture for the london olympic games
o  one of his most important works can be found at the liverpool art biennale
in the renowned tate gallery in
london
20 to 50 a sculpture
made of engine oil
it is the only permanent
installation in the museum i
only ever approach the topic of architecture as a
sculptor for some reason
the empty space seems to exist  being my starting material in architecture
some artists create their works from
material that they previously
bought in the shop i construct create
or destroy the space that architecture offers me
for the sculpture in
heathrow's terminal 2 a total of five
international artists were asked by
richard wilsons  the idea was awarded
more than three million euros to
build slipstream the airport
is a public space
people will certainly not make a special
pilgrimage to rome to see the sculpture
but 20 million passengers are
expected in this terminal and i
hope that  everyone somehow
also busy with it because you just ca
n't overlook it you
can see this especially with the passengers
who are testing the airport this was what
is the cliq sending a photo
i find it very interesting that the
pictures from slipstream are also traveling again
richardson's giant sculpture is the new
flagship of the airport
heathrow not only the longest work of art in europe
but maybe also soon the
most viewed one